[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm here at the Guinness Factory in
Dublin everybody thinks I'm here to
shoot a funny remote segment but
actually I'm just here for free Guinness
this was my idea I don't care if we
don't get five minutes of footage
don't freak in us I'm standing here with
Kira
you're a storehouse assistant here at
Guinness is that right yeah we're going
to get to sample some Guinness maybe and
of course but not right now and no oil
me okay what would you like to start up
to tour tell me what I need to know this
leaf in the center is the least Arthur
Guinness finds in the year 1759 it's her
9,000 years just enough time 9,000
airlie yes this is the ingredients
section of the Guinness door light
storehouse yes that sound you hear is
people urinating after a lot of Guinness
is that correct it is not graphics the
sign of our Luiza waterfalls oh that's a
waterfall I'm sorry I assume we also
have the party we have popped and also
our very special society Easter ruff so
all four ingredients come together to
make together
I'm gonna guess that you're gonna want
to show me all four ingredients well
usually on it's war yes if I can do
three pull-ups on this steel beam right
now can I have some Guinness
[Applause]
quickly
I'm sorry it's okay so this is what
makes the Guinness the barley it's the
essence of a do cats ever wander in here
because it looks a lot like him you know
yeah would go is there any chance that
like chewing this I would in fact get
the effects of having a pint of Guinness
huge mistake could I put this back oh
it's selling on eBay
[Music]
[Music]
yeah can we want to do this city users
that's the smile of a man's who just got
a farmer to sign a 9000 year lease what
is your name
John I'm told that who guess who I am
like Italian TV yes TV yes yeah yes
genius that's right it is indeed it was
that based on the time who harp in the
year 70 no to look at a snake on the top
he'll get his face he can't believe I've
had to wait this long for the wall of
fame anyone famous equals to Guinness
Storehouse when you try and get a
photograph to the Guinness Storehouse
with appreciation of best wishes from
the crew of Air Force One I don't know
how I feel about that thanks for all the
Guinness now we're going to fly the
president this is a president having
some Guinness just before his first
debate with Mitt Romney there's the
Queen Bill Clinton of course yeah Paul
Rudd
kid paul rudd get free Guinness I can't
tell you that information I'm Stephanie
look at him smiling that's a guy it'll
be a great photograph right here yeah he
pitched this to you coming off Ryan
getting his lifetime supply of Guinness
imagine right here most people did not
have to go through a whole tour I think
a lot of them got their Guinness right
away I think the president got his
Guinness right away
I think Jorge Garcia got his Guinness
record I've been taking through the
history of oats barley
grains hops I've watched them grow I've
watched you till the fields it's all
part of the learning process though it's
really important that you know what's
going on okay let's go and see how the
steel was made to make the building and
then how to concretely support shall we
no no I think we should be thorough
don't even get your points of Guinness I
actually have someone I have to
introduce you to and his name is Fergal
Murray on to the monster brewery hello
Fergal mr. O'Brian you're very welcome
you're haunting me with an empty glasses
noticing that we said speaking for an
over an hour and a half and you're going
like this to me I'm waiting for you to
say you close at least showed me how to
fool one the six fantastic steps yeah I
have a feeling it's gonna turn into 11
steps very soon step one I've got my
glass 225 degree angle
swimming okay now what did I do wrong
first thing you can do is follow
instructions perfect
I tried to make Guinness myself once at
home I took a loaf of pumpernickel bread
and put it in the blender and then
buried it in the yard for about six
weeks
you see what they do when they drink in
is how the digit to do never look down
and find a Guinness this is bad man it's
always look to the horizon look to the
horizon we'll get over what and to pull
the liquid through the head and finding
the glass with my tongue
okay and then you sit underneath the
phone yes horizon are you still here I
can't see it there oh I couldn't try
more slide in nice smooth answer that
actually yes here you go here's fro hold
on one sec it's someone who works here
hello Pia you well done you're great
[Music]
[Music]
show me oh good now try to pretend
you're not dressed
[Music]
[Applause]